and so something that we can do at home
right now uh everybody you know
this is a box but if you have a chair
what can you do with it all right so
what you can do with this right now is
i'm gonna show you guys how to box squat
all right you can do these over
intervals or you can do these through
reps
intervals time simply chest up sit down
keep your heels rooted through the
ground all right you can speed up
you can slow down if you want to get
fancy if you have weights at home
you can add water you can add things
around the home that weigh yourself
but this is something that's simple that
we can do all right anything
you said the key is also kind of keeping
your knee above your
uh above your ankle right kind of
keeping a 90 degree angle yes absolutely
while you're working you want to
maintain proper form so you want to have
your heels
in the ground 90 degree angle as you sit
you want to have your heel beneath your
kneecap you don't want to have any more
than that
all right chest up push up lower
yourself down
push up lower yourself down so all of
that i mean like you said with the chair
you can start moving your body right
immediately and this is something again
you can do right now at home if you
don't have to get out and put on this
pair of sneakers and go to the gym or go
out and do a walk maybe again starting
right now in a chair that you're in
is something that everybody could
probably do right now
thank you